en este vídeo necesitaremos recordar
estas relaciones ere cuadrada es igual a
equis cuadrada más 100 cuadrada x es
igual a r por el cose no detecta y es
igual a r por el seno de teta y hay una
con tangente pero no la vamos a
necesitar en el primer ejemplo nos piden
que graphic hemos r igualados y miren si
yo fuera igual a 2 eso querría decir que
debemos graficar una línea que pasa
porque igualados entonces cuando ya es
igual a 2
es como si tuviéramos una línea en la
que ponemos puntos a todo lo largo de y
cuando es igual a 2 formando una línea
horizontal ahora sí eres igual a todos
pasa algo muy parecido podemos poner un
punto en donde sea que el radio pueda
ser igualados porque en este caso no nos
interesa cuál es el ángulo theta
entonces aquí tenemos un radio igual a 2
y si se dan cuenta al marcar el radio en
todos los ejes obtenemos una
circunferencia ahora si sustituimos el
valor de r en la primera ecuación es
decir ere cuadrada igual a equis
cuadrada massieu cuadrada nos queda que
r es igual a la raíz cuadrada de x
cuadrada massieu cuadrada y eso es igual
a 2 ahora si elevamos ambos lados al
cuadrado podemos deshacernos de la raíz
y nos queda que x cuadrada macià
cuadrada es igual a 4 y miren x cuadrada
massieu cuadrada igual a 4 es la
ecuación de una circunferencia con un
radio igual a 2 y con centro en el
origen entonces esta sería otra forma de
graficar lo sólo habría que convertir
esto a coordenadas cartesianas ok ahora
graphic hemos cr igual a la tangente
detecta por la secante detecta bueno voy
a escribir la tangente como seno de teta
/ coseno de teta
también sabemos que la secante de teta
es uno entre el coche no detecta y la
razón por la que hago esto es porque
para obtener las coordenadas en términos
de xy jr y poder graficar las
necesitamos tener cosenos y se nos
detecta ok entonces que tenemos aquí
bueno r es igual a seno de teta entre
jose no al cuadrado de teta y ahora
simplemente multipliquemos ambos lados
de la igualdad por coseno al cuadrado de
teta así nos queda que erre por el
coseno al cuadrado de teta es igual a
seno de teta y ahora lo que podemos
hacer es multiplicar ambos lados por r y
nos queda que r cuadrada por coseno al
cuadrado de teta es igual a r porsche no
detecta observen que así ya tenemos cr
por seno de teta del lado derecho
entonces podemos sustituir esto porque y
de este lado en realidad tenemos r por
coseno de teta porque lo podemos
escribir
r por coseno de teta al cuadrado y ya
sabemos que esto es igual
porsche no detecta entonces r por coseno
de teta al cuadrado es igual a equis
cuadrada y r por seno de teta es igual h
así es cómo logramos obtener una fórmula
que podemos graficar en coordenadas
cartesianas y tal vez ya saben que esa
ecuación es simplemente una parábola que
se abre hacia arriba ok entonces cómo
pueden ver es muy interesante ver cómo
pasamos de esta forma polar a una
expresión más familiar en su forma
cartesiana y lo hicimos simplemente
usando esas relaciones hagamos otro
ahora tenemos teta igual a menos pi
entre 6 am bueno esto es como el caso en
el que erre es igual a 2 pero ahora
donde sea que el ángulo es igual a menos
pie entre 6 porque esta vez no nos
interesa cuál es el radio entonces si
dibujamos el
cuando es igual a menos bien 36 nos
queda un poco hacia abajo y el radio va
hacia afuera en esa dirección
e igualmente si lo reflejamos como si
tuviéramos un valor de r negativo así es
como nos queda la gráfica cuando teta es
igual a menos pi entre 6 o que hagamos
uno más en este caso vamos a graficar
ere cuadrada menos 3 r
2 bueno la forma más fácil de graficar
esto es factor izando primero supongamos
que esto es igual a cero así tiene más
sentido
entonces para graficar r cuadrada menos
3 r 2 igual a 0
podemos factorizar lo como r - 2 por r
menos uno igual a cero así al resolver
los factores sabemos que r es igual a 2
o también que r es igual a 1 entonces
primero graphic hemos cuando r es igual
a 1
nuevamente obtenemos una circunferencia
radio es igual a 1 y si gráfica mos r 2
obtenemos una circunferencia cuyo radio
es igual a 2
esta es la gráfica de la ecuación polar
es re cuadrada menos 3 cr + 2 igual a 0
en otro vídeo veremos algunos ejemplos
más complicados y graficar hemos tomando
en cuenta el ángulo teta y haremos la
transformación de coordenadas polares a
cartesianas